speaking of division by the way joe
biden
and the democratic moderator because
they were losing the debate went back to
the only emotional attack line that has
consistently worked
throughout the trump administration it's
the only terrible awful thing they can
accuse trump of which is
he separated children from their parents
at the border right put put kids in
cages
but you put kids in cages you monster i
would never do that
so they launched that line of attack but
trump was prepared for it
they got separated from their parents
and it makes us a laughing stock and
violates every notion of who we are as a
nation
let me ask you a favor they did it we
changed the policy your response
let's talk about who built the cages
let's talk about what we're talking
about
well we're talking about the cages well
let's i want to talk about what we're
talking about i don't want to be talking
about the thing we're not talking about
who built the cages joe well i don't
want to talk about that
because the biden the biden the obama
biden administration built the cages
those photos that were going around
showing kids in cages and was so awful
and trump's the devil
turns out those photos were from 2014.
president trump doesn't get elected
until 2016. they were from
the obama administration so he cuts him
off right there
and then he makes a point about these
kids separated from their parents very
often
they're not being brought over by their
parents
the talk about immigration now gentlemen
and we're going to talk about families
within this context mr president your
administration
separated children from their parents at
the border at least 4 000
kids you've since reversed your zero
tolerance policy
but the united states can't locate the
parents of more than 500 children
so how will these families ever be
reunited
children are brought here by coyotes
and lots of bad people cartels
and they're brought here and they used
to use them to get into our country
we now have as strong a border as we've
ever had
we're over 400 miles of brand new wall
you see the numbers and we let people in
but they have to come in legally and
they come in through how are you
reunited
so it's it's not president trump's fault
necessarily that he didn't have the
answer on this
and none of us i think knew the answer
on this until the department of homeland
security came out with it
but the premise of that question is
complete bs
right now there are 485 cases
where kids have been separated from
their parents
and it's under litigation not in
one single case has the department of
homeland security
found the parents and the parents wanted
the kids back
in their country of origin not in one
case
485 cases have
the parents have been contacted by the
department of homeland security and said
we've got your kid here
we will reunite you with your kid in the
country of origin
not in one case have the parents wanted
the kids back
why because they're sending their kids
to america there could be a perfectly
sympathetic or you know understandable
explanation for this
but don't tell me that donald trump
won't unite the kids with their parents
they're doing their best dhs would like
nothing more
than to unite the kids with their
parents in their country of origin
but that doesn't mean that you get to
just blow out the open borders and
and abolish our immigration laws and let
anybody come in
we already let what two million people a
year in vast majority of americans want
that number to be
dramatically lower by 50 or more
according to some polls
can't do that can't do that and if the
parents don't want their kids back we
can't make them
take the kids back trump mentions that
these coyotes these you know these
criminals are bringing
the kids over apparently some some
people on the left
don't know what coyotes are there was a
state representative
darshan kendrick darshan kendrick is a
state rep in georgia tweet that
did donald trump just say 545 kids can't
find their parents
for came over through cartels and
coyotes
how the heck does a coyote bring a whole
human across the border lord stop
talking
final debate thank you when i saw that i
thought
it i guess she's kidding too i
i there's no way she really but i think
actually
she thought he was talking about the
animal coyotes
not the criminals who are animals
frankly if you ask me
uh bringing the human beings across i
just love that idea like good lord stop
talking are you that stupid trump
when people say that very often
they are the ones who are missing
something such as david hogg he was that
kid
who became a micro celebrity after
a school shooting and he he led the
fight to
essentially abolish the second amendment
and then he was admitted to harvard for
doing that
david hogg tweeted out imagine calling
the immigrant parents that bring their
children to the united states for a
better life
coyotes the level of xenophobia is
sickening
and again i wish i wish he i could say
he were kidding but i suspect
he is not he is not and we
need to raise the voting age in this
country how old is david august like 19
years old or something like that
he should not be voting he should
whatever whatever age he is
we need to raise the voting age above
that number he's at harvard by the way
so he is
at least according to the liberal
establishment he is
one of the truly elite intelligent
young young people in this country and
still
certainly should not be voting i hope
you enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts